we're going to explain all 11 Blackbeard
Pirates their devil fruits and their
crazy backstories including all four
major new abilities the manga just
reveals like kuzan formerly known as
Admiral aokiji who has just been
confirmed as an official member of
Blackbeard's crew this was hinted at by
one of the five Elders of the World
Government after kuzan lost the battle
for the fleet Admiral position against
Akainu kuzan wields the powerful here
hinomi a lokia fruit that turns its user
into true coldness aokiji can cool down
anything around himself including the
ocean itself turning it into ice making
him the only known devil fruit user who
would be immune to falling into the
ocean this as well as his former Admiral
status most likely make him the most
powerful subordinate Blackbeard has in
his crew at this moment with
ridiculously overpowered devil fruit and
hockey abilities kuzan's character is
inspired by the actor yasuka matsudam
especially in his role of detective
shunsaku Kudo that if you look at it is
really just an in real life version of
aokiji his epithet literally means blue
pheasant which is inspired by both his
ice powers but also by the story of
momotaro which was accompanied by a dog
a monkey and a pheasant which also gets
you the Red Dog kainu and the yellow
monkey kizeru as for aokiji's role in
the crew of Blackbeard it's really hard
to say what's his actual position is as
we've literally just found out that he
is an official member however out of the
10 Titanic captains in Blackbeard's crew
we only know nine of them so it really
wouldn't be too far-fetched I think to
assume that kuzan might be the Titanic
captain of the 10th ship but why on
Earth did a former Marine Admiral Join
one of the most evil pirate groups on
the planet in the first place I think
it's pretty fair to say that kuzan is
the odd one out in a crew of already
fairly odd Pirates well he was Luffy's
antagonist during the long ring island
arc and later on at marineford Ichiro
Oda the author of One Piece has made it
pretty clear to us that kuzan was really
more of an ally to the crew than
anything he was the one who spared
Robin's life after the events on O'Hara
and was cheering for her to find a place
where she belongs aokiji's entire art
during the water 7 and sloppy Saga was
literally a test for the straw hats to
see if they could actually be entrusted
with Robin's life as alkiji explains
himself he sees his Idol GARP Luffy's
grandfather in the straw had Captain
himself and soap starts to cheer for him
always finding an excuse to spare their
lives yes he freezes Robin and Luffy but
then just leaves he has a heartwarming
chat with Robin after the crew saved her
from endless Lobby and makes sure that
everyone who helped Luffy infiltrate the
island is categorized as simply an
innocent bystander then he just lies
down on his sunbed as Garb lets his
grandson Escape hand Smiles at the
crew's new ship and even at Marine Ford
he saves Luffy's life twice first
jumping in to attack Luffy with a really
basic stab attack while Akainu was
getting ready to take Luke fee out
completely and then later on letting
lost Submarine Escape as they treat the
heavily wounded Luffy so overall kuzan
is presented to us as one of the most
powerful Marine Fighters that then
sympathizes with Luffy's Journey because
Luffy's and his sense of justice overlap
and yet after all that after losing the
battle with akaino he joins none other
than Blackbeard Luffy's polar opposite
and a man with no sense of morale and
Justice whatsoever the three most likely
explanations here are that one he has
truly changed his ways and is looking
for revenge on the Marines two he is an
undercover agent for the Marines and his
fight with the kind who was just staged
to get him into the crew in the first
place or three kuzan is actually working
with or for someone else for example the
revolutionaries to keep an eye on
blackbeards and assure that he doesn't
succeed with his mission to rule the
world I personally find it really hard
to believe that kuzan is not a good guy
who will at some point come to help
Luffy and the crew and turn on
Blackbeard sometime later on in the
story I mean he might even be the person
who reveals the decisive detail of how
to bring teach down in the end so once
the straw has crossed paths with the
Blackbeard Pirates I don't expect kuzan
to really fight anyone at all but if
anything switch sides at number 10 we
have Jesus Burgess Burgess is one of the
double fruits that have just been
revealed in the manga sometime after the
events address Rosa he has eaten the
rikiriki no me a paramecia that grants
superhuman strength now this comes in
especially handy here because it
multiplies Burgess already superhuman
base strength to a level where he's able
to easily lift an entire freaking
mountain and casually throw it this
makes him the physically strongest
member in the crew by far Jesus Burgess
is inspired by the classic Mexican
wrestler theme including the mask and
all thus when his face is shown for the
very first time is unmasked well we
actually aren't quite see it fully
because similar to the Mandalorian it is
shameful in Luchador culture to be
unmasked and having one's true identity
reveals the name Burgess is most likely
inspired by the real-life pirate Samuel
and Josiah Burgess and Jesus is both a
traditional Spanish name Jesus but
funnily enough Oda also gave Burgess
Christmas day as his actual birthday in
reference to actual Jesus now there's
really pretty much nothing that we know
yet about burj's background apart from
that he was one of the original members
of the crew and joined Blackbeard due to
his Passion For Fighting strong
opponents he's the Helmsman of the crew
and captain of the first ship suggesting
that he might have been teacher's very
first member but we do not know for sure
now while some people have thrown Sanji
in as a potential opponent for him I
like to think that as hellsman of the
crew Burgess will fight jimbei the
Helmsman of the straw hats both of them
do have the stature of a wrestler and
are practicing Martial Arts number nine
is Studio of the rape probably my
personal favorite in the entire crew CDO
has eaten the sukisukinomi a paramecia
type devil fruit that renders its user
invisible this fruit was taken from its
previous owner Absalom in the cruise
hunt for powerful devil fruits stealth
abilities are Beyond convenient and give
shiryu a strong tactical advantage over
his opponents together with his superb
swordsman skills Oda has revealed that
shitiu has become teacher's right-hand
man and the second strongest member of
the crew after his captain that's a this
color spread here now since aokiji was
not revealed yet at this point and
because he most likely isn't even an
actual member anyways I don't think we
have to break our heads figuring out who
of the two is actually more powerful
right now shirio doesn't seem to have
any obvious Inspirations at first glance
however his Japanese name and Katana as
well as his epithet of the rain strongly
hint at shiriu being a former citizen of
wano that would of course perfectly
explain his excellent sword fighting
skills that make him the swordsman and
captain of the second ship of the
Blackbeard Pirates before Magellan
shiryu used to be the head Jailer of
impel down the government's terrifying
prison of death and torture were each of
its six levels is modeled after Dante's
Inferno in other words literally hell
and yet somehow shiryu was deemed to be
too cruel and brutal for a place that
already seems to be the most brutal and
cruel place in all of One Piece so as a
result for his methods he was sentenced
to death and thrown into level 6 the
secret deepest level where those are
being kept whose crimes were too
terrible or embarrassing for the
government to be made public during
Luffy's breakout Magellan reluctantly
chose to release CDU temporarily to help
him quench the uprising instead once
shirio got his hands on his swords he
immediately killed all of his guards and
cut off all Communications to the
outside of the prison fearing that
Magellan might come down to get him then
later after Blackbeard and his men were
dying from Magellan's poison shirio
brought them the antidote and accepted
Blackbeard's second invite to join his
crew he then helped them to reach level
6 to pick the strongest inmates for the
crew Cito clearly joined for his insane
bloodlust and Menace since the
government deprived him of it well he
now joined Blackbeard that gives him a
new opportunity to live out his very
worst instincts and it does seem pretty
straightforward then that as a Samurai
and the second strongest in the crew
chiriyu will of course face Zorro and
possibly be his biggest challenge on the
story next to mihawk coming in at number
eight is Von auger another member whose
devil fruit has been freshly revealed he
has eaten the wapuwapunomi a paramecia
type devil fruit that literally allows
teleportation both of himself and of
others this is of course a perfect fit
with his sniping abilities vanagar has
incredible precision and is able to take
out moving targets from miles away which
he does demonstrate on Jaya as he takes
out seagulls flying off the coast of the
islands these seagulls have done nothing
wrong why would you anyways the fruit
also allows the black Bay Pirates to
quickly change locations or bring a
target of theirs close to them and it
also allows for an Auger to teleport his
victim wherever he wants and then simply
shoot them which is pretty wild both his
outfit and design as well as his sniping
powers are inspired by the character
Adolphus from Terry gillum's film The
Adventures of Baron minchausen Adolphus
is one of The Baron's henchmen with
perfect eyesight and Flawless shooting
skills able to detach an apple from a
tree about 900 miles away so that one
checks out I guess van auger's name is
inspired by both the real life pirate
John auger as well as the augers who are
Roman priests that would read the future
by interpreting the flight patterns of
birds which fits pretty well with his
introduction he's both the crew sniper
and captain of the Third ship now we
don't actually know anything yet about
vanaga's past apart from him being the
only member from the East Bloom the sea
that does seem to produce a lot of high
quality snipers somehow and of course
the only suitable opponent for him is
going to be the straw hat sniper Usopp
next we have number seven the corrupt
King Alvaro Pizarro there is pretty much
nothing that we know yet about Pizarro's
Powers except that he is one of the
level 6 input down prisoners so he must
be pretty damn strong and he was even
confident enough to try and take command
from Blackbeard at some point he does
look a lot like some of the Beast
Pirates including the horns which could
suggest a Zone type devil fruit but
there is really no way of saying Pizarro
is inspired by Francisco Pizarro the
Spanish conquistador that conquered Peru
and basically single-handedly destroyed
the Inca Kingdom which is very fitting
as Alvaro Pizarro used to be king of a
country in the North Blue that then
overthrew him for his cruel way of
ruling in the end however he's actually
gotten his wish granted of becoming a
captain as he Now commands the fourth
ship of the Blackbeard Pirates now since
we know nothing about his powers and
fighting style the most likely matchup I
have for him is Sanji as he does seem to
be quite powerful in the hierarchy of
the crew also he did used to be a cruel
ruler which as we know should create
some real PTSD for Sanji and growing up
under his terrible Father Judge number
five is the demon Sheriff Lafitte
Lafitte doesn't have an official devil
fruit quite yet but we have seen him
flying with giant white angel-like Wings
this could of course mean that he is
part of one of the winged races or
alternatively that he's eaten some sort
of winged devil fruit maybe that of an
Angel which would be nice and iconic
with his devil slash demon epithet
Lafitte does look quite fragile but
seems to be quite powerful he's capable
of hypnotizing people which might make
jungle relevant again at some point in
the story I guess
soon jungle
and he was also able to invade marijua
completely undetected until he made
himself to be known during the warlord
conference Lafitte is inspired by the
real-life pirate Brothers Jean and
Pierre Lafitte used to be a police
officer in the West Blue until he was
exiled for his repeated police violence
and cruelty there on top of that lafit
is also the original Navigator of the
Blackbeard Pirates which does seem to
put him up against Nami which I find an
incredibly interesting matchup
especially since Nami also uses
Illusions to fight her enemies as well
coming in at number 6 is the Crescent
Moon Hunter Katarina Devon the only
woman in the top Echelon of Blackbeard's
crew really Devon has eaten the mythical
dark dog food model nine-tailed fox as a
Kitsune she's able to shape-shift into
other people arguably making her an
advanced version of bonkrey's fruits
interestingly enough Devin was once the
worst female criminal within the Golden
Age of piracy before she got sent to
imple down which is fascinating because
big mom was a thing back then as well
her name might be inspired by the
Spanish conquistador kataina de rauso in
early Concepts released in the SPSS Oda
planned her originally to be a really
cute Fox girl as a member of the
original Blackbeard Pirates however in
the end he decided that Blackbeard's
crew should look more authentic rough
and vulgar and thus changed her design
turning the cute Fox furry theme into a
devil fruit which you know too bad as
the only female Titanic captain it would
be very much like Oda to match her up
with Rob in them and in a way their
abilities do seem to be quite an
interesting matchup here by the way
quickly if I hit 700 Subs by the end of
November I will make a whole video about
shanks's crew and all the powers that
Oda has revealed together with film red
so do hit subscribe if you do want to
see that number four is another impel
down escapee the Colossal Battleship San
Juan wolf now this character is
fascinating in a lot of ways for one he
is the largest character in the entire
story barely fitting on an island and
usually just seen towering somewhere in
the background I mean dude look at this
thing he's also the first known Giant in
the story that has actually eaten the
devil fruit and what we don't exactly
know what that devil fruit is it does
seem to make him quite a lot bigger as
Giants and one piece do tend to get very
old with 99 years he is the oldest
member of the crew his name could be
based on the Spanish worship the San
Juan nepo muteno and somehow he is also
one of the 10 Titanic captains now I
really don't know how he would fit on
any of the ships maybe he can just
shrink himself as well after all or he
is the ship I mean who knows we really
do know nothing about his powers but he
does look quite powerful even if
remember boys and girls size isn't
everything but it sure leaves an
impression if you know what I'm saying
my best matchup for Wolf right now would
be Frankie a character that also has a
gigantous robot at his disposal and
after leaving from vegapung's Lab might
very well have upgraded to something
even bigger and more impressive than
Shogun Frankie that can actually keep up
with San Juan wolves unfathomable size
number three is Vasco shots and out of a
crew of people we know very little about
he is by far the worst the only two
things we really know about this
character are that he ate drinks a lot
and B that he has apparently the longest
nose of any other one piece character
and yeah that's it I have high
expectations that his powers must be
something incredibly powerful and
entertaining because I'm a big fan of
drunken fist fighting and other
unpredictable abilities of that sort and
there does seem to be a pattern here
because just like the other level 6
inmates that blackbit has recruited his
name also seems to be based on another
Spanish conquistador Vasco Nunez de
Balboa and shot probably just refers to
doing shots really the only straw hats
left without a match up here is Brooks
so I'm just gonna go with that not
Chopper of course because at number two
we have the god of death doc cute dog Q
has eaten the shiku shikunomi literally
the six Sig fruit that allows him to
infect his opponents with diseases that
apparently he can just come up with
himself including apparently something
called turning into a woman's sickness
which makes me wonder if usop's I can't
go to that Island sickness might not
actually become a relevant and real
thing again at some point in the story a
very fitting devil fruit for a character
that has been chronically sick his
entire life but also sort of ironic
given that he's the crew's official
doctor his palen sick horse that is
fittingly named stronger has eaten the
mythical Pegasus Zone fruit giving him
the ability to fly when I was quirky as
this prayer may seem we all know that
they are quite powerful and despite
their pitiful appearance they love
tormenting people as we saw with docu
giving out explosive Apple to random
people the inspiration for his character
is twofold Doc Q fits the description of
death the fourth Horseman from
Revelation also known as The Apocalypse
in the Bible death is described as a
gone figure who writes a sickly and Pale
Horse spreading disease very fitting and
of course there's also the Snow White
poison apple story on top as well but
interestingly enough doc Q also shares a
lot of similarities with Dr hiruluk
Choppers mentor and father they both
have a very similar face and hair color
both first appeared on drum Islands both
are criminals a con man and a pirate and
both have a love for chemicals while
docq infuses Apple so that his victims
explodes you look at the end drank a
chemical that also made his body explode
as a result of course the only
acceptable opponent for docu and
stronger is Chopper who will have to
face a dark and twisted version of his
mentor and father figure which brings us
all the way to number one the Admiral
role of the Blackbeard Pirates the man
the myth the legend himself Marshall D
Teach as you know Blackbeard has eaten
two devil fruits at this point the logia
yamiyami Nomi that gives him the power
of darkness and the most powerful
paramecia fruit the guraguranomi that
allows him to create powerful
earthquakes this makes him possibly the
most powerful Pirate Of Life at this
point and we also finally have gotten
confirmation that Blackbeard does in
fact have hockey as well something that
really wasn't that clear up to this
point as for Blackbeard's past how he
was able to eat those two devil fruits
and what his big plan really is well I
explain all of that in this video right
here so do go watch that next if you're
interested